how worried are you about a second wave
of coronavirus and another acute public
health crisis I think we're all
concerned about another outbreak it
would be devastating for those that were
infected and devastating for the economy
if we're going to avoid that we need
mass community testing we need a very
effective test trace and isolate scheme
which isn't in place at the moment but
we need a better plan for dealing with
any local outbreaks in Leicester there
was too long a delay between knowing
about the outbreak and something
actually being done about it
what's your biggest concern about the
preparedness of the NHS for the winter
crisis very important is that for
vaccines for ordinary flu if you like
influenza a ramped up and we're calling
for vaccination for all of those over 50
it would be the perfect storm this
winter if we had an outbreak of
influenza at the same time as the
possibility of a second spike in Kovach
because the symptoms are very similar
theme sage advice back in April was that
this needs to be done because you can
just imagine what will happen if people
present with flu symptoms thinking
they're kovat symptoms and that could
then lead to a surge of cases you're
over 50 so you'll be getting a flu
vaccine this winter will you well if the
scheme that I'm proposing is rolled out
I would be but and it's very important
that everybody over 50 does get it and
just in terms of the government and the
NHS they put millions into the health
service over the crisis what would you
have done differently I mean they have
put their money into the health service
haven't they criticism of the government
has been that it's been slow in its
decision so it's the speed of decisions
that's just got to improve going forward
if we're to prepare for what might
happen this winter Nicola Sturgeon and
thinks that the Prime Minister is living
with high levels of infection rates in
England because he wants to reopen the
economy do you agree with that
assessment we've supported the
government on the principle of easing
restrictions it is important that we get
our economy open again in a safe way
it's very important we get our children
back into schools but we've got to
balance that against the risks because a
group of scientists have also said that
the Prime Minister should hold an urgent
inquiry now to learn the lessons and
understand how we should be better
prepared what's your view of that an
inquiry now when are we going to have it
I think an inquiry is inevitable but at
the moment I've been pressing the
government or the action the action
that's needed now to prevent a second
outbreak and to test as many people as
possible into last year there will be an
inquiry in due course
when are you going to actually call for
it and say when it should be well it's
the moment at the moment I think it is
important that we concentrate on the job
in hand which is ensuring that we've got
the health crisis under control and
we're about to have an economic crisis
coming down the track you say that you
want to lead by constructive criticism
of the government how would you rate
their handling of the crisis is it 5 out
of 10 8 out of 10 2 out of 10 I think
that they have not done it well because
they've been slow slow to recognize
problems slow to respond to brought
below average performance well how would
you rate the government to slow asleep
at the wheel
and they really need to up their game 5
out of 10 4 out of 12 I don't know what
about out of 10 but you I think what the
public want is a government that
recognizes problems and deals with them
swiftly of what we've got in the Prime
Minister is a prime astir who refuses to
see problems has he failed the public
the Prime Minister what these made
mistakes and has been far too slow and
you do better job that I think we can
see that historically I think you do a
better job what I would do is to
recognize problems and be honest about
those problems explain them and fix them
Joe Biden said Boris Johnson is a
physical and emotional clone of
President Donald Trump do you agree with
that I don't I wouldn't describe him in
that way how would you describe him a
prime minister
who does not acknowledge the problems
that are right there in front of him who
pushes away challenge when it should
invite challenge and who is flippant
about some of the risks that we face it
so you think he's a poor leader I think
that he's not led us through this crisis
in the right way so you think he's a
poor leader he refuses to see problems
for what they are and that leads to
mistakes do you sometimes feel a bit
envious that he seems to be able to sort
of cheer the country on that somehow he
is quite charismatic my concern about
Prime Minister is that he's good on the
rhetoric but he's not good on governing
and there's a big gap between the
rhetoric and reality you said when you
were elected to be leader that you
wanted to end factionalism in the labour
party one of the most striking decisions
you have taken has been to sack Rebecca
long Bailey who is the heir if you like
to the Corbin ISM project and the wing
of that party do you understand why four
people on that win the party people that
Becky that voted for her that looks very
factional from you as a leader the
article that Rebecca lone Bailey tweeted
about was anti-semitic I asked her to
deal with that and I then took the
decision when she did that we had to I
had to remove her from the Shadow
Cabinet that was the right thing to do
is to do with the bus not how our
supporters feel about it I think that
you're trying to cut that section of the
party adrift that's how they feel this
is not a left-right issue I have no
intent as had purged the party at all
just one more question on black lives
matter you said the other day that you
thought it was a shame that the movement
had got tied up in organizational issues
do you think there's a widespread
structural racism issue in our country
and if you do how can it not be tied up
with organizational issues well I
support black lives matter we have deep
pockets of racism we have widespread
discrimination and
but this has to be a defining moment so
many people have said to me this needs
to be more than a movement it needs to
be the moment when the world actually
comes together and does something about
it people call it a turning point but
you were worried that by supporting
calls to defund the police would
alienate a group of voters that you will
need to embark well the calls to defund
the police advised some involved in the
campaigning I think here in the UK
everybody recognizes that actually we
need more funds for our police we
certainly need more funds for other
areas mental health the health service
education housing you name it but
certainly my argument we we need more
funding for our police in this country